A tonsillectomy is the
surgical removal of the palatine tonsils,
two structures located on both sides
of the back of the throat.
Normally, the tonsils have the
function of preventing infections by
helping to destroy
harmful bacteria and other germs that
enter the body through  through the
nose and mouth the adenoids located
under and behind the soft palate
have a similar function
Tonsils generally become enlarged and inflamed
when fighting an infection this
condition is called
tonsillitis tonsillitis may be
related to fever sore
throat painful swallowing  and
swelling of the lymph nodes in
the front of the
neck is most commonly diagnosed in
children but can also be seen
in some adults. Although there are a
number of indications for
tonsillectomy the most common is
recurrent tonsillitis or
Chronic inflammation of the tonsils.
adenoids, usually due to
allergies, can cause blockage of
the fallopian tubes, increasing the risk
of middle ear infections and
related hearing loss. An
adenoidectomy is the
surgical removal of adenoids.
Tonsillectomies and adenoidectomies
are usually performed at the same time.  When you arrive
at the hospital for the
procedure, you will have an
IV and may be
given a sedative to help you
relax. Most
procedures use
general anesthesia, so you will be asleep for
the entire duration of the operation.
A breathing tube will be temporarily inserted
through your mouth and
throat to help you breathe
during the operation. Ambiathomas
and adenoidectomies are rarely
performed with local anesthesia in adults
and never in
children. During tonsillectomy, the
surgeon will use a special retractor
to keep  the patient's mouth
open and a tongue depressor to
ensure a clear view of the
tonsils the surgeon will grasp one
tonsil at a time with
tonsil forceps, detach it from the
surrounding tissue and remove it with a
noose or tonsil grasper
Electrocautery or clamps and
ties will stop any bleeding
that occurs in the area where
the tonsils were removed. Generally
this area heals naturally without
stitches. The procedure for an
adenoidectomy is very similar to that of a
tonsillectomy. Both
procedures can usually be performed in  20
to 60
minutes after the operation you
will be taken to a recovery room until
the effects of the anesthesia wear off,
which usually takes between 8 and 10
hours. It is normal for
tonsillectomy patients to return home the
same time.  day of
procedure